serait ton aujourd'hui face à une erreur
judiciaire de grande ampleur c'est la
question que l'on peut se poser à propos
de la sphère que nous allons évoquer à
présent patrick dils un jeune homme âgé
de 29 ans est en prison depuis 12 ans il
avait été condamné pour le meurtre de
deux enfants à montigny les metz en
moselle hier le parquet général a
demandé la révision de sa condamnation
des soupçons sérieux pèserait sur le
tueur en série francis heaulme faignot
vernis
après douze ans de prison patrick dils
pourrait être innocenté hier l'avocat
général près la cour de cassation a
demandé la révision de la condamnation
le 27 janvier 1989 alors âgée de 17 ans
patrick dils été condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pour le meurtre
de deux enfants alexandre et cyril avait
été retrouvée lapider le long d'une voie
ferrée après avoir avoué le jeune homme
s'était finalement rétracté treize ans
après les faits un nouvel élément vient
relancer l' enquête la présence de
francis sommes dans la région à l'époque
des crimes ce tueur en série a déjà été
condamné trois fois par la justice et
mis en examen dans cette autre affaire
si francis heaulme n'a pas reconnu les
meurtres d'alexandre et cyril il admet
s'être trouvé sur les lieux au même
moment une coïncidence qui incitait
bruno cotte l'avocat général a requis
rire la révision du procès de patrick
dils la commission de révision rendra
son arrêt le 21 juin si les magistrats
rouvre le dossier il pourrait dans le
même temps remettre patrick dils en
liberté